a few old photographs in a couple of
letters that's the only proof Jensen has
that he is relative somewhere in North
Korea it would put them in danger to
show their faces on television his older
brother Chen sign tells me fought for
South Korea in the Korean War almost
seven decades ago Changsha Bok was taken
prisoner by the north the family was
told he had been killed but then 60
years after seeing his brother for the
last time
Chiang Saen received a letter from North
Korea from his brother delivered through
a contact in China that was 10 years ago
it made Chung sign happy and sad at the
same time when I saw the photo
I couldn't instantly tell it was my
brother but you can see how depressed he
looks like I remember him as such a
cheerful person his brother passed away
shortly after Cheng signed up the letter
but he left behind a family of his own
chan hopes that with thawing relations
between North and South and the upcoming
summit he might finally get the chance
to meet his relatives as I get older my
desire to meet them is growing stronger
I want to get to know that side of my
family now with the summit no teams more
likely will have a chance to meet with
you I'm still not sure if I should trust
the politicians but I just can't help
but hope it'll finally sunshine isn't
the only one in South Korea getting his
hopes up
many here believe that the summit will
produce a positive outcome maybe even
paving the way for a peace treaty to
finally end the Korean War sixty-five
years after the last shot was fired and
more and more South Koreans are even
changing their mind about North Korea's
dictator Kim jong-un himself you know
TPA always seemed to by what he said in
what he got the impression he's actually
leading the country chu churu clarity I
waited across the inter-korean summit
changed many people's opinions about
that doesn't change the fact in an
oppressive communist regime is the
biggest issue during the meeting as a
Korean I have the impression that Kim
has sold the will to give up the weapons
I hope the US North Korean summit will
produce expect something positive
based on the inter-korean summit a few
weeks ago I would like to hear something
great such as a declaration to end the
Korean War sometimes tanks sign and his
wife come to the National Cemetery in
Seoul to find his brothers name on the
wall of missing soldiers even though
Changsha balk is no longer missing
they don't want his name deleted Seoul
was his home they say they hope that
maybe one day his children in North
Korea can come here too
you